نتابع معكم هذه الصور التي وصلتنا الان
ونعرضها لكم على شاشه العربيه لاحد
الاسواق في سوق الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم كنا
نتابع معكم هذه الصور وننقلها لكم حتى هذه
الساعه طبعا كان هناك اصوات من قبل
المواطنين خصوصا في جنوب الخرطوم ونتحدث
عن منطقه الكلاكله بالذات لانقطاع الكثير
من المواد التي يحتاجها المواطنون خصوصا
فيما يتعلق بالادويه الطبيه جراء العدد
الكبير من الاصابات وبعضهم تحتاج الى علاج
واصاباتهم خطره فيما الاصابات الطفيفه
بالتالي هناك نقص في الادويه الى جانب نقص
الماء والوقود والكهرباء وحتى قطع
الانترنت يعني نتحدث عن ابسط مقومات
الحياه يعاني منها المواطنون طبعا نتابع
معكم دائما هذه الصور والمشاهد التي تردنا
لحظه بلحظه حتى اليوم مازال الان يعني
تقريبا تقييم لحتى هذه الساعه الهدوء
الحذر هو سيد الموقف فيما عمليات الاجلاء
هي العنوان الرئيسي والعنوان الابرز حتى
هذه الساعه من قبل بعض الدول اليوم نرصد
لكم هذه الصور والمشاهد في صباح هذا اليوم
في سوق الكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم طبعا اليوم
الاعين تتركز اكثر على ولايه الخرطوم
بمدنها الثلاث طبعا نتحدث عن العاصمه
الخرطوم انظر من وايضا الخرطوم بحري حيث
ان الاشتباكات تتركز حدتها في هذه المناطق
دون غيرها في السودان فيما هناك اشتباكات
وايضا مواجهات متفرقه في اماكن اخرى في
السودان ككل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات